[Musique]
on est étudiante éducatrice de jeunes
enfants
on vit à lille on doit faire un stage de
trois mois et on part au québec
[Musique]
pour moi le québec c'est les espaces
verts
c'est les grands froids des lacs le
saint-laurent trois fois plus grand que
la france pour neuf fois moins
d'habitants le québec est la plus vaste
des dix provinces du canada
premier producteur mondial
d'hydroélectricité à la 6e place pour le
pétrole deux tiers de ces échanges se
font avec les états unis sont moins
qu'avec ça représente les cabanes en
bois
les sirops d'érable l'autre sur glace le
mélange des langues
80% des quelques 8 millions de québécois
sont francophones la belle province est
l'un des bastions de la langue française
son combat contre l'anglicisation a fait
date dans le mouvement de la
francophonie le premier ministre jean
charest est l organisateur du forum
mondial de la langue française en 2012
c'est aussi le caribou
annecy m'diq larry et clémentine sont
toutes les trois en formation à lille
pour être éducatrice jeunes enfants elle
s'apprête à partir pour trois mois en
stage au québec
elle compte bien tester l'accueil
légendaire des québécois et profiter de
la richesse de la nature de la province
alors pourquoi ce voyage au québec
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à aller au
québec toutes les trois en fin pour
découvrir ce pays qui est assez avancé
au niveau de la petite enfance donc
c'est pour ça que c'est très intéressant
voit là bas trois mois ça va nous
laisser le temps de visiter douay de
voyager de découvrir le québec
nous on va essayer de vous aider à
préparer ce voyage en répondant à vos
questions a priori comme ça ce que vous
avez déjà des interrogations
j'aimerais bien peut savoir comment ça
fonctionne bah justement ce pays
pourquoi une province française en plein
milieu de temple est cernée par des
millions de fans l'ophone comment
fonctionne le fédéralisme là bas quel
type de décision relève de du québec la
province et puis après bas du canada
tout entier
les deux se vivent ensemble quelles sont
les différences
ok on va regarder
pour répondre aux questions des
voyageuses sur l'histoire du québec et
sa place dans la confédération
canadienne nous allons rencontrer
jacques portes
il est professeur d'histoire d'amérique
du nord
à paris huit jours chaque part bonjour
caroline
[Musique]
alors nos voyageuse aimerait connaître
un peu l'histoire de ce pays au moins
une province comme ça francophone s'est
retrouvé au milieu de millions d'animaux
rue jacques-cartier c'est le premier qui
est découvert en train de guillemets le
canada
[Musique]
mais il ya eu pratiquement un siècle
entre jacques cartier et la foison de
québec 508 ayant pas trouvé ni métaux
précieux ni rien bah ça ne pas tirer
trop
il a fallu attendre donc le début du
17ème siècle pour que de nouveau des
gens qui voulaient qu accepter de partir
là-bas tout changé avec l'indépendance
américaine
quand les états unis deviennent
indépendants ça va provoquer à ce moment
là un afflux d'anglais aussi bien le
territoire la nouvelle france que dans
d'autres parties du canada avant il
avait très peu il est resté une
concurrence entre les anglophones et les
francophones
oui c'est à dire que là et le la
province de québec qui croise au québec
quand après la confédération du cac avec
un gain de 67 a été le refuge des
canadiens français qui s'appelait pas
encore québécois et qui ont vécu en
cultiver leur identité identité donc été
française et catholique pour l'essentiel
un début d anglais avant la
confédération ça va aider de noyer les
collégiens français sous la masse
anglophones sont et comment ils ont
réussi alors à préserver la réussite
parce qu'il y avait une natalité très
forte parce que s'ils se sont renfermés
se faire par enfermer m'enfin ils se
sont développés l' identité propre parce
que le français est la langue officielle
maintenant est la langue officielle ou y
il ya une langue officielle du québec
est contestée par certains parce que l
briderait les efforts économiques des
entreprises mais c'est depuis leçons de
17 c'est la langue du chart des lois
françaises
[Musique]
et quand les analyses et les politiciens
anglais une anglophone s'aperçut qu'il
ne pouvait pas être majoritaire
finalement ils sont arrivés à faire des
compromis sans arrêt entre les connais
français gagner anglais qui a abouti à
la confédération où chacun soit chez soi
et donc et ils ont gardé ce côté là
jusqu'aux années 60 si on veut dans le
cas de la confédération en développant
toujours un pièce d'identité un peu
retardataires parce qu'à côté un peu
rencontre le progrès marqués par
l'église catholique car tout cela est
donc le tout se fait ce phénomène là
donc de retard relatif du québec grève a
éclaté à partir des années 60 ce qu'on a
appelé dans une expression qui a été
ensuite imité en france la révolution
tranquille et c'était l'idée donc qu'on
pouvait faire une révolution sans ce
sens là sans la force
finalement et sans violence est un tout
petit peu de violence mais pas tellement
peu que c'est comme très marginal est
donc là il ya eu un effort de
modernisation incontestable québec
médiation culturelle des des gens comme
le charlebois com
félix leclerc et autres littéraire avec
des auteurs nouveau michael herr blé des
tas de gens comme ça et politique aussi
puisqu'il s'est agit de renforcer l'état
du québec et d'en faire véritablement un
état à partir des années 60 avec l'aide
de la france cette fois ci qui a accepté
d'aider après de gaulle surtout après 37
à essayer d'aider des maximums
développement du québec comme état parce
que le pari de vol et écrivain
indépendant un jour oui vive le québec
libre bien sûr 28,7 france entière c'est
voir entend ce qui se passe ici et je
puis vous dire qu'elle en vaudra mieux
vivre montréal
vive le québec
le québec libre
et ça ça et des biens sur la place et
pas tellement le les québécois même la
place elle québec sur la carte du monde
enfin faire que ça existait et justement
le mouvement indépendantiste qui a eu
des tentations un peu de violence ième
avenue des attentats des morts
aujourd'hui on en est où il eut des
référendum ou plusieurs pour
l'indépendance et qui ont chaque fois
abouti à un non
[Musique]
touchés
aujourd'hui c'est les indépendantistes
qui passe quel poids politique le
problème c'est ça c'est que le bâti
québécois avait été co fondée sur l'idée
d'indépendance du québec
mais en même temps une fois que
maintenant la perspective de référendum
s'éloigne le parti québécois en lui même
perd une part de son identité qu est-ce
qui n'est fait pourquoi il ya toujours
une très forte personnalité que les
coins et pas changé mais aussi le dire
c'est à quoi ça sert d'aller plus loin
il n'empêche pas que le québec grâce en
partie au parti québécois dans les 76 à
82,15 et tout ça a quand même balisé son
identité incontestablement
enfin ils sont quand même situation qui
est toujours un petit peu ambiguë mais
par rapport aux 15 ont ils sont pas ils
sont deux dans 100 m haies a justement
pour comprendre comment marche un peu ce
fédéralisme canadien parce que ce qui
intéresse nos voyages eux c'est par
exemple tout ce qui concerne
les lois sociales et notamment séquence
à la petite enfance mais pour faire un
stage
oui pour dans l'éducation des enfants ce
type de décision là il est pris au
niveau du gouvernement du québec où ce
sont des lois canadiennes mois ans et 10
ans soit essentiellement tous les
domaines de l'éducation des lois
sociales des services sociaux c'est
strictement provincial
des fois le coup en fédérale plus loin
et des bancs de subventions binh ça y
est ça ne s'oublie pas de ces questions
ainsi vos collègues pas mais aussi à
situer à peu près par là et
du coup j'aimerais me rapprocher plus du
centre et sinon tu as vu comment je
voulais pas me nicolas que je préfère
être avec des anglais habiter le clergé
tu veux rester dans le quartier
anglophone du prêt tant qu'à faire
autant en profiter à fond de la langue
peut être sensible au fait que le québec
fait partie d'un mouvement de défense de
la francophonie
je pense que c'est important est de
soutenir ça l'anglais a tendance à
prendre le pas un peu partout à travers
le monde et de se dire que bon il ya ça
persiste dans certaines certains pays on
a envie que ça continue
[Musique]
au québec la langue joue un rôle
primordial puisque les québécois qui
sont francophones sont cernés par des
millions d'anglophones et l'un des
meilleurs outils de défense de la langue
française c'est la chanson on va
rencontrer maintenant une star de la
chanson québécoise coeur de pirate qui
est en concert en france
bonjour bonjour le français la langue
française pour vous est-ce que qu'est ce
que ça représente
les françaises c'est une langue qui
malheureusement n'est plus parler
beaucoup c'est dommage passé seulement
qui est très belle et d'en faire un
rejet comme ceux de l'ape a réduit et du
québec ont misé pour tout le monde au
québec c'est par les français est de la
france par moment où si je vois beaucoup
gens qui y chantant en anglais
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui sont un
petit peu menacé onze ans que la langue
et elle survient le film et je pense
qu'elle va toujours rester l'un de cette
façon on la défend tellement bien à
notre façon notamment grâce à la chanson
c'est l'une des armes selon vous pour
pour défendre allons prendre aucune
éducation aussi et ce qu'elles sont en
général
[Musique]
alors ya un sujet tabou entre les
français et les québécois c'est l'accent
ouais nous retrouve que vous en avez
vous vous trouvez que nous on en a ce
que c'est et non pas comme vous vend aux
xvième siècle c'est ça je sais pas
apparemment ces données moi j'y suis
donc quand les gens disent ou les gens
me regardent gens mais tu t'en vas je
vous envoie sur ton cheval est ou non
mais ouai j'avoue qu'on on a un accent
vous avez maintenant on a tous un accent
il n'y a pas de ces intrus qui vous
énerve qui voudrait que moi ça m'énerve
ça ça m'énerve pas du tout et est-ce que
vous avez quelques expressions typiques
québécoise qui vous viennent à l'esprit
ouais j'ai envie d'y magasiner on me dit
ça passe par faire du shopping ses
magazines est tombé en amour comme en
amour c'est marc cherry ouais et je te
manque blonde
on avait beau se plaindre parce que au
canada au québec on dit quand je perds
ma blonde et sur mon amoureuse le
premier album parlait mon adolescence
alors que là je parle de mon passage à
l'âge adulte et mes histoires d'amour du
coup donc comment j'ai aimé dans un
contexte où c'était plutôt un peu fini
pourquoi parce que j'avais aucune idée
de comment ça se passe et fonctionner
des relations amoureuses en fait je
connais je connaissais rien parce que
quand j'étais ado j'avais justement pas
de tgv populaire à l'école un podium et
puis james comme ceux ci une autre
aujourd'hui ça va mieux au ouais ça va
ça va quand même mieux
[Musique]
il ya deux boutons éclaté sur ton com
qui me repoussait qui fait l'âme auront
deux pouces et à mon âme que la tournée
qui suit article
[Musique]
je
vous avez envie de vous intégrer
pleinement dans la société québécoise
moi je crois que c'est une volonté vous
en avez déjà eu une approche cependant
nos recherches de stage on a été en
contact avec les directeurs de
structures et moi j'ai été assez étonné
par la convivialité dont ils font preuve
et puis le tutoiement si tu prends ça ça
vous a surprise oui oui agréablement du
coup ça va donner qu'à l'image de la
société québécoise ou qu'est ce que vous
avez envie d'enfin savoir en partir on a
une image de montréal avec ses grands
ses gratte-ciel cette nature autour et
moi je les imagine très écolo on se
demande aussi un peu comment les gens
vivent à l'intérieur de cette ville
vu que c'est l'amérique du nord est ce
qu'ils sont beaucoup influencé par par
l'amérique le côté le côté usa ou alors
côté un peu plus européen
voilà comment ça s'organise au quotidien
non voyageuse ont bien l'intention de
s'intégrer dans leur pays d'accueil
allant même envie de faire une
colocation avec des québécois du coup
elle voudrait connaître leur mode de vie
société plutôt à l'européenne
ou plutôt à l'américaine on en parle
avec maria blacks à ce journaliste
québécoise qui vit à paris
bonjour laquelle bonjour
[Musique]
la voyageuse ont d'emblée été frappée en
passant leur coup de téléphone par
l'accueil qu'elles ont reçu des
québécois et le tutoiement immédiat est
ce que la chaleur légendaire des
québécois est vraiment réel
c'est ce qu'on dit c'est vrai que c'est
une des choses qu'on entend très
régulièrement et surtout de la part des
français sont que l'accueil ou là le
caractère jovial ou accueillant des
québécois passe par autre chose que le
tutoiement fait c'est ce que c'est une
population particulièrement tolérante
j'ai oublié toujours de comparer avec
l'associé française mais plutôt à les
rentes sur la différence peut-être moins
normative un petit peu moins
conformistes mariage gay est autorisé
par aigle au mariage gay est autorisée
mais pas qu'au québec dans toutes les
provinces donc voilà c'est peut-être pas
propre donc le au québec toutes les
religions sont respectées ou plus ou
moins même si parfois ça à cause des
petites frictions et ça commence à en
cause est de plus en plus même quelque
chose que j'ai déjà vu au canada que
j'aurais jamais vu en france était un
policier qui portait qui était sic et
qui portait ce turban sur la tête donc
qu'il portait pas le chapeau des
policiers qui paraît képi lama mais je
pense que ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourra jamais voir en france et
justement surtout à montréal qui est une
ville très multiculturelle très métissée
savoir si chaque communauté si c'est un
peu à l'anglais c'est très communautaire
ou si c'est plus mélangées je pense
qu'il ya un idéal de mélange
or comment ni vision se rend compte que
malheureusement les communautés vivent
souvent en ghettos les chinois restent
entre eux et par le chinois donc c'est
difficile finalement d'entrer en
relation avec cette communauté qui reste
très fermée sur elle-même
je pense qu'il ya un idéal de mixité
mais il n'est pas toujours
vraiment aboutie sauf pour évidemment
les enfants d'immigrés qui le sont à
l'école francophone
parce que c'est obligatoire et par le
français ensuite way forcément se mêlent
à la population
clary elle a été plutôt marqué par les
images de gratte-ciel surtout à montréal
qui lui donne l'impression que c'est
un état très américanisée alors est ce
que c'est une influence américaine qui
domine ou est-ce que c'est l'héritage
français
comment ça se passe la dualité est la
chose qui prend le pas sur l'autre c'est
une question très intéressant parce que
quand j'étais là-bas j'étais persuadé
que les québécois étaient assez
européens dans leur manière de vivre
mais en fait en vivant en france depuis
dix ans je me rends compte à quel point
c'est une société très américaine dans
ses valeurs dans dans son économie dans
sa politique de plus en plus donc je
trouve que c'est une société qui est
finalement beaucoup plus américaines
qu'européennes et qui s'américanise de
plus en plus et d'ailleurs j'ai vu des
statistiques sur les études durant
québécois qui font des échanges à
l'étranger et la france et l'europe
apparaissent beaucoup moins maintenant
comme des destinations de rêve pour pour
étudier que les états unis donc j'en ai
bien risque pour le
la francophonie du québec à votre avis
ah oui je pense de toute façon montréal
maintenant a basculé il ya plus
d'anglophones que de francophones
et oui je pense qu'il ya danger réel
pour la francophonie bien sûr non voyage
aux halles ont le sentiment que c'est un
c'est un état le québec particulièrement
tournée vers l'environnement un pays
très vert avec des comportements très
écolo est ce que c'est le cas je ne sais
pas au québec c'est un rapport à la
nature qui tellement immédiat je sais
pas si un respect mais en tout cas il ya
une ça fait tellement partie du mode de
vie que de faire soit du camping aussi
l'été ou être par dell à la chasse par
exemple je sais pas si c'est une
question de respect c'est juste que
c'est beaucoup plus immédiat est
naturelle en hardox allemand c'est l'un
des pays qui investit le plus d'argent
dans l'exploitation du gaz de schiste
mais hennaoui les nappes phréatiques
sont polluées pour beaucoup d'entre
elles et de production d'eau gms capa
hiatus en fait entre la richesse des
ressources naturelles et parfois
l'exploitation qui et c'est pour ça que
je vous dis que je ne suis pas du tout
certaines de ces comportements
écologistes il ya aussi eu des scandales
sur la coupe des arbres pour les pâtes
et papiers restent à sud et la
déforestation ou finalement on coupe des
feuillus pour remplacer par des
conifères et du coup ça bouleverse
complètement la faune et la flore c'est
pas un pays si vert que ça non par
contre c'est vers en quantité pas dans
les comportements pendant est d'ailleurs
généralement aussi le fait de passes
vivre dans cette abondance encourage pas
aussi des comportements de gaspillage ou
justement parce qu'on sent que la
ressource comme s'ils étaient infinies
c'est un peu déçu par les non-verts
commis comme quoi mais bon je pense que
oui ils sont quand même influencé par
par ce qui les entoure et puis
on passa n'empêche pas que des dérivés
et c'est le côté économique qui prend le
dessus
une des raisons pour lesquelles on a
choisi ce pays c'est qu'on pensait que
c'était un pays vraiment vert écolo dans
les pratiques au quotidien au cinéma
dans l'autre
la richesse et l'immensité de la nature
c'est l'un des principaux atouts
touristiques du québec la forêt recouvre
plus de la moitié de la superficie de
l'état c'est l'un des plus grands
réservoirs d'eau potable de la planète
on va en parler avec anne caroline dumas
les guides du routard bonjour bonjour
alors le québec est connu pour
l'immensité de son territoire et pour la
richesse de sa nature surtout la forêt
recouvre plus la moitié de la superficie
des réserves des parcs nationaux
voyageuse voudrais savoir en fait quels
sont les sites qu'est ce qu'elles
peuvent découvrir en ce qui concerne la
richesse de la nature du québec
c'est vrai que le québec est connu pour
ses grands espaces c'est vrai qu'ils ont
su comme les américains préserver très
très bien tout c'est tous ces espaces en
aménagement
toutes ces réserves de nature en parcs
nationaux en réserve faunique etc il
faut reconnaître que c'est quelque chose
qui c'est un travail admirable donc pour
ça effectivement ils vont tout a été
préservé impeccablement très bien
organisé voilà parfaitement administrés
donc c'est vrai que l'observation
d'animaux par exemple des baleines
est très importante au québec
l'observation des baleines est devenu
une activité phare dans l'industrie
touristique québécoise quels sont les
autres animaux possèdent des noms qui
font rêver un peu les caribous voilà
alors effectivement les caribous et les
orignaux on peut les voir on peut les
voir en pleine nature
ya pas deux il ya pas d'observations
organisé on va dire de ces animaux alors
qu'il ya des observations organisé de
baleines ya des observations organisé
d'ours aussi qu'on peut aller voir
d'ours noirs c'est la seule espèce
d'ours que l'on peut voir au québec et
elles ne seront pas déçus ça c'est
évident le québec est aussi connu pour
la rudesse de ces hivers 120 à 160 jours
par an je crois 6 à 8 ans pète comment
on s'y prépare que doit que font les
habitants et que doivent faire donc les
voyageurs pour affronter cet hiver alors
effectivement il faut être si on les
québécois ils ont l'habitude de gérer
ses hivers même s'il reste un défi il
faut il faut arriver effectivement a
passé cet hiver qui peut durer jusqu'à
avril
mais aujourd'hui dans la société moderne
entre le confort des maisons l'isolation
thermique les doudounes high tech tout
le monde arrive à s'en sortir et les
québécois sont très très bien équipée
pour sa salsa peut descendre jusqu'à
quand même moins 30 je crois à peu près
faut se préparer on part pas au québec
en hiver sans avoir un certain
équipements et puis on y va aussi pour
faire un certain type d'activité qui ne
sont évidemment pas les mêmes que l'été
donc on peut on peut faire du ski de
fond pour ceux qui aiment on peut faire
du ski alpin à moins de deux heures de
montréal il ya la station de
mont-tremblant qui est une petite
station qui accueille aussi bien des
skieurs de fond que dès que des skieurs
alpins
on peut faire des balades à moto neige
ça marche très très bien avec un réseau
qui est assez unique au monde je crois
on peut faire des balades en chiens de
traîneaux de notre activité qui est qui
qui plaît beaucoup
on peut faire des balades en raquettes
on veut faire de la pêche blanche
donc pour ceux qui aiment la paix s'il a
la pêche en fait à travers la glace dont
vous voyez les activités ne manquent
demande pas comme le chantait charlebois
il aime se marier avec l'hiver ils ont
l'habitude de se marier avec l'hiver il
aime aussi la sortie de l'hiver il a
célèbre qu'est ce qu'ils font en fait
elle a donc au moment où le redoux
réapparaît enfin donc la neige commence
à fondre c'est la période des fêtes où
on saigne les érables pour extraire le
fameux la fameuse scène en fait qui
donnera après le sirop d'érable
donc on fait chauffer cette sève et on
l'a répand sur de la neige propre et en
fait ce sirop se transforme un peu en
sucette et c'est ce qu'on appelle la
tire d'érable et c'est une coutume
typiquement québécoise qui que les les
habitants ont plaisir à retrouver chaque
année tous les habitants se retrouvent
dans les cabanes à sucre pour fêter sept
tirs merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
là bronzé richesses naturelles est l'un
des principaux atouts du québec alors
sur quoi repose son système économique
comment se porte le marché du travail
c'est frédéric lefret de l'office franco
québécois pour la jeunesse qui nous
répond bonjour frédéric lefret bonjour
[Musique]
donc on a vu que le québec était très
riche en ressources naturelles donc sur
quoi repose son économie est ce que
c'est justement l'exploitation de ces
ressources
alors les richesses naturelles sont une
exploitation très importante d'ailleurs
quand vous regardez dans le pib du
québec vous avez trois axes le premier
c'est tout ce qui concerne les métaux
normalement l'archet la richesse bien
évidemment du sol ensuite vous avez tout
ce qui est nouvelles technologies
quelque chose de très important au
québec
et évidemment on le connaît par
bombardier l'aérospatiale qui est
quelque chose de très important qui
d'ailleurs ce à peu près 10 7% du pib au
niveau de l'énergie
la spécificité c'est long d'accord donc
hydro québec qui est quelque chose
d'énorme au québec qui permet bien
évidemment d'exporter l'électricité
aussi bien d autres côté de la province
du canada mais surtout aux états unis
c'est un des premiers des plus grands
fournisseurs au monde d'électricité et
justement les échanges en dehors
l'électricité les échanges commerciaux
seront essentiellement avec les états
unis alors à deux tiers avec les états
unis
la crise est passée et actuellement les
entreprises québécoises et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs mois aux tic du cercle des
dirigeants franco-québécois l'entreprise
ce qu'on fait systématiquement c'est
qu'on essaye de faire en sorte que les
québécois exporte plus avec l'europe et
on allie les partenaires la ville et
partenariats la crise nous a donné
raison
étant donné que beaucoup d'entreprises
québécoises était lié avec les
industries automobile des états unis la
crise a fait que malheureusement ça a
moins fonctionné et maintenant les
entreprises québécoises se disant on va
rééquilibrer et on va aller de plus en
plus vers l'europe et notamment vers la
france d'accord alors justement ce
qu'elle voudrait savoir à nos voyages
c'est un peu comment une québec a
survécu à la crise où survit encore
puisqu'on en est pas sorti est-ce que
les spécificités comme ça on peut dire
que le québec a bien traversé la crise
quand vous voyez qu aujourd'hui le
québec est la province qui aura plus de
toute croissance en 2012 du canada ils
vont être à peu près à 2,2 pour cent
vous voyez un petit peu ce que ça fait
par rapport à la france en plus ils ont
un système qui leur permet d'avoir bien
fonctionné d'ailleurs le monde entier
vient voir le fonctionnement des banques
canadiennes
simplement parce que depuis les années
80 les banques canadiennes d'affaires et
de détails sur ces parts et donc à
partir du moment où les banques
d'affaires ont eu des problèmes
il ya eu aucun impact sur le crédit on
est au point de vue des particuliers des
entreprises au québec en matière de
crise quand vous regardez la démographie
du québec et son activité économique 8,2
millions d'habitants d'ici 2016 1,2
million d'emplois pour voir ce qui est
énorme pour un pays et donc il ya une
attirance
pour le québec en ce moment et notamment
les québécois font beaucoup pour que les
francophones et les français en
particulier puissent venir au québec
travaillé et travaillent c'est une
immigration travail et les francophones
sont privilégiés tout à fait est
vraiment dans les francophones les
français
alors justement elle no3 voyageuse elles
partent en stage pour l'instant mais
elle n'exclut pas pourquoi pas si elle
s'y plaisent d'essayer de rester
travailler là-bas dans le domaine de la
petite enfance
ce sera facile ou pensée pour elle alors
facile ça se prépare ça se prépare nous
petit de l'office franco québécois pour
la jeunesse nous c'est ce qu'on fait on
est de 7000 jeunes chaque année à se
préparer à travailler au québec et sur
le domaine de la petite enfance et son
de la chanson sur un secteur porteur
les québécois sont très novateur dans
tout ce qui est politique sociale par
exemple ce sont les premiers pour la
petite enfance et ce qu'elles vont
découvrir qu'ils ont inventé ce qu'on
appelle la pédiatrie sociale
ça permet dit que vous avez un enfant en
âge de 3 à 4 ans où on décèle quelque
chose qui me convient pas à partir de ce
moment là il ya toute une équipe
pluridisciplinaire qui a terni auprès de
l'enfant des parents de la famille des
voisins et des gens qui habitent autour
est leur leitmotiv c'est vraiment de
mettre la prévention en avant et est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres comportements d'autres
conseils que vous donnez pour compte
bien se comporter dans une entreprise et
est finalement bien être acceptée alors
le conseil s'est tout simplement de ne
pas avoir peur du tutoiement le
tutoiement est de rigueur
donc ça s'est très très bien ça permet
de s'intégrer et ne pas hésiter à donner
à donner des idées
dans toutes les entreprises où on place
des français qui vont travailler trois à
douze mois
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit tout
simplement qu'à chaque fois qu'un
français propose quelque chose contre
armand un stage dans une entreprise
française
les québécois disent bien essayons au
niveau du recrutement ce qui est
privilégiée ça avant tout vos
compétences humaines
c'est à dire votre savoir être après
évidemment on va regarder si vous avez
les compétences techniques mais que si
vous n'avez pas un bon caractère ceci
est pas capable de travailler en équipe
et d'apporter quelque chose de nouveau
vous êtes moins privilégiés qu'on
regarde - le cv les diplômes et c'est
pour ça que nous par exemple nous
excusions donne des cours de cv
à la québécoise pour permettre aux
jeunes de mettre en avant tout ce qu'ils
ont fait en dehors de leur train de leur
travail par exemple finalité pour la
personnalité souza travaille dans une
association si vous attaquez ce que les
québécois aiment passer quelqu'un qui
soit un cv va avoir que des diplômes et
rien autour
merci beaucoup aux frais la 4è merci
il
m bano mire sceptique quand même ça
alors ça y est c'est le grand départ
ouais vous êtes près par un peu d'allant
dans l'avion
on va arriver et qui est
découvrir cette société découvrir alors
pour finir de préparer votre voyage vous
a amené quelques petites choses le
dernier album de coeur de pirate blonde
qui veut dire si vous avez bien suivi ma
copine en mon amoureuse en québécois
bravo la traversée du continent un roman
de michel tremblay et puis ça c'est un
classique un vieux romans maria bonita
écrit en 1913 et qui a participé de la
conscience collective québécoise
merci amusez vous bien envoyez nous une
nouvelle agréable
ouais la merci à voir
si vous aussi vous souhaitez quand vous
aide à préparer votre voyage envoyez
nous vos destinations envisagées à
l'adresse et si on partait at public
point senat.fr et on se quitte sur des
nouvelles de morgan et nicolas qui
partait en inde dans la dernière
émission
à bientôt
[Musique]